Right.
Well better get started because there's quite a lot of ground to cover today as
you'll see from the handouts.
Um,
okay.
Well we all know that Henry the eighth had six queens,
you know,
divorced,
beheaded,
died,
divorced,
beheaded,
survived.
Um,
and that makes good television and bad television too.
And all of those,
all of those queens are marked on your handouts in the appropriate place in bold
Q one to Q six.
Uh,
but the real reason that his reign was so important in English history is of
course that he initiated the English reformation,
a momentous change with very far reaching consequences.
And Henry's interesting marital career was essentially part of that larger
process set in train by the wheel of a powerful king.
Well,
for that reason,
the English reformation was once famously described as being essentially an act
of state,
its essence being the transfer of legal authority over the church in England
from a distant papacy to a very present English crown.
The Universal Catholic Church in England became the Anglican Church of England.
So an act of state and an active state.
It certainly was.
It was initiated by the crown and directed from above and carried through by
successive acts of parliament,
and yet it was also of course so much more than that because these acts of state
also inaugurated fundamental changes in the religious culture of the nation.
Looking at the whole,
it's certainly possible to distinguish us,
Christopher.
Hey does a series of legislative reformations.
On the one hand,
Andrew distinguished that from on the other hand what he terms the Protestant
reformation,
which was a much more gradual and much more diffuse process of religious change
extending over generations and yet the two dimensions of the reformation,
the legislative and the Protestant inevitably went together.
What was once seen as being a very purposeful process of change.
Carefully directed,
swiftly accomplished now tends to be seen as a much more hesitant and uncertain
business,
but to call the whole thing as Christopher,
hey does a series of blundering steps is perhaps to go a wee bit too far
because there certainly was purposeful action and the reformation process became
much more deliberative over time as the issue is gradually became clearer and as
the religious alignments to which it gave her eyes gradually crystallized
Christopher Hayes a counterfeit or provides us with an excellent overview the
details of which take the narrative up to 1,603 but what I want to do in the
lecture today is to emphasize the contributions of each phase of development in
the crucial generation from the late 1520s through to 1558 the various stages
which contributed to an emerging religious division.
And I want to try to bring up the logic of those phases of development.
All of this can be very confusing in the details,
but there is a certain logic to it.
And that means in the first instance,
grasping how successive political situations gave rise to particular
developments,
which had consequences for religious change one way or the other.
And then later on in section discussion,
we'll explore further the larger question of the extent to which these changes
were welcome or unwelcome for the people at large and a very gradual process of
their acceptance.
So let's look at the first phase,
which ran roughly from 1527 to 1531 which we can call,
you know,
the gathering crisis.
Well,
if there was a phase of blundering about as Christopher Haigh puts it,
then it came at the beginning.
And it was occasion of course by the fact that the king and his advisors were
facing a completely unprecedented situation.
In 1527 Henry needed a male heir.
As you know,
the future of the Tudor Dynasty and of the political stability,
which had had reestablished,
might hang on that fact of an undisputed succession.
Henry was 36 his wife Catherine was in her early forties no child was now
likely.
Now,
as you know,
Catherine had originally come to England as the bride of Henry's older brother
Arthur,
who had shortly died and she had subsequently married Henry Brooding on this.
Henry by 1527 became preoccupied with a biblical texts.
Leviticus 2021 which translates as if a man shall his brother's wife.
It is an unclean thing.
He has uncovered his brother's nakedness and they shall be childless.
And at the same time,
on a somewhat less principled notes,
Henry's,
I had been caught by a young woman of the court and Berlin,
whom he saw as a potential new queen.
She was in her early twenties the Vaishyas ambitious and astute.
And she was not willing to be the king's mistress.
She intended to be queen.
So Henry needed to get his existing marriage dissolved.
He needed it to be declared void from the beginning by the pope and to take a
new queen.
And it should have been very easy.
Since pope's,
we're usually willing to cooperate with the needs of kings in such matters.
But it was rendered difficult by two factors.
First of all,
Catherine was a very strong personality.
A sense of honor was outraged by the idea that her marriage should be dissolved
in this way.
And in 1527 as matters began to reach your head,
her nephew,
the emperor Charles,
the fifth of the Holy Roman Empire of Germany,
gained control of the pope,
Clement the seventh in the course of his Italian wars.
Now all Henry really needed was a delegation of authority from Rome to settle
the matter.
And in 1628 it looked like he might get it.
In that year,
a paypal ambassador,
cardinal compared geo,
was sent to England and he and Cardinal Thomas Woolsey.
We're empowered to establish the facts regarding Henry's marriage,
but in hearings that they inaugurated in 1529,
queen Catherine vigorously defended the validity of her marriage.
She denied that there had been any sexual conservation to Prince Arthur Henry's
elder brother.
She embarrassed the king by publicly declaring that he knew she had been a
virgin when they married.
She defended her,
her,
uh,
her honor and her marriage.
And then in July,
1529 new victories,
victories of the emperor in Italy meant the pope was even more firmly under his
control and the pope revoked the case back to Rome.
So the first phase of the developing crisis was efforts to put pressure on the
papacy by threatening the privileges of the church in England in order to get
the pope to cooperate.
In September,
1529 Cardinal Woolsey who had clearly failed,
Henry was threatened with illegal charge of primary Neary,
which was an offense established by statutes in the 14th century regarding the
jurisdiction of church and state within England,
he had allegedly illegally exercised his powers as the pope's legate in England.
And a couple of months later,
parliament was called and the members of parliament were encouraged by royal
counselors to lay complaints,
not only against Cardinal Woolsey,
but also against other alleged abuses in church affairs.
So at this stage,
Henry is blustering.
He was deliberately stoking up the latent resentment of clerical privileges
amongst members of parliament.
But as yet there was no intention to go further indeed having set things going
in this manner,
fired his warning shots as it were.
The king sent parliament into recess between December,
1529 and January,
and in the meantime,
he assembled a think tank of academics and clergy to prepare his legal case for
a divorce.
And he began consulting learn opinion amongst lawyers and theologians from
Europe's various major universities.
But none of this had the desired effect.
And in 1530,
the pope cited Henry to appear before him in Rome and forbade him to remarry
until he did so.
The king was both frustrated and furious
and he found reasons to fail to comply with the pope's requirements in the
materials which were being assembled by his academic research team.
Uh,
these survive and then known as the collector Yana.
And they included some crucial arguments.
One was the argument that historically the church in England had exercised
independent provincial rights.
That's to say it had the right to autonomy in the settlement of certain internal
affairs without reference to Rome.
The second crucial argument which they put forward was that within England,
the king enjoyed imperial power,
not only over the state,
but over the church in matters which were not of a strictly spiritual nature.
So Henry still hoping for a change in the European political situation,
which would lead to paypal cooperation.
Use these ideas to put a bit more pressure on the church.
In 1530 his lawyers indicted the entire clergy in England for primary Neary
illegally acquiescing in the exercise of Papal Authority.
The convocation of the Church meeting at Canterbury resisted,
and Henry demanded that they recognize his supreme headship of the church and
they eventually did so they recognized his authority,
but only so far as the law of God allows a saving clause.
And they gave the king a grant of 120,000 pounds from the church to try to
sweeten his mood.
Yeah.
So where are we?
In 1531 the king and the church have fallen out badly over Henry's need for a
dissolution of his marriage.
The central issue has been clarified.
The central issue has become that of legal jurisdiction of the papacy over the
English church and therefore its ability to frustrate as divorce since the
church had authority over marriage.
But there was no question of any doc trinal challenge to the Roman Catholic
Church.
No challenge in matters of faith or matters of worship.
This is a legal issue at this point,
which brings us to phase two,
the royal supremacy
as 1531 advanced.
There was no indication that the pope was going to give way and the political
impasse precipitated the second phase of development,
the royal supremacy,
and it was masterminded by Thomas Cromwell between 1532 and 1535 now brief word
on Thomas Crum.
Well,
he was a man of very humble origins,
the son of a London plus worker and tavern keeper.
He had had a,
an obscure early career.
He'd probably served as a soldier in Germany.
He'd worked as a merchant and eventually he went into the law in a six in the
1520s he gradually emerged as a very skillful man of business in the household
of Cardinal Woolsey,
much trusted by Woolsey for his astuteness and competence.
And in 1530 when Woolsey fell,
such was Cromwells reputation that he was taken into the king's service and by
1530 was made a member of the council
and it was Cromwell who saw the way out of the legal impasse through a carefully
planned program of legislation.
Can you exactly what he was doing?
A memoranda in his own hand survive,
which show the stages of his planet.
And in 1532 to 34 his strategy of making Henry's divorce possible and then
legitimizing these changes was executed stage by stage through the careful
presentation of the king's desires to parliament and management of parliament to
get them past,
first of all,
they put still more pressure on the church to break any resistance within
England.
Parliament was brought to pass the act in restraint of an aids and aids were
payments to Rome,
which were made when bishops will appointed.
This canceled them,
but the act was held in suspension as a threat to paypal finance.
Secondly,
the House of Commons put forward what was called it's supplication against the
ordinary's,
a petition against the exercise of ecclesiastical jurisdiction in the church
courts in England and the abuses which allegedly took place.
This was an attack which provoked the convocation of the church,
its own assembly to reject the accusations.
Henry then rounded angrily on them and demanded their full submission and it
May,
1532 they caved in,
the convocation submitted and abandoned its claim to legal jurisdictional
independence
the way it was now clear in England,
but there was still no response from Rome
and then fake land to hand.
In August 60 1532 the Archbishop of Canterbury,
Archbishop Warren died,
Henry and Cromwells managed to secure the appointment and the confirmation from
Rome of Thomas Cranmer as the new Archbishop of Canterbury.
A Cranmer was a Cambridge academic who had taken a great interest in the early
development of Protestantism in the 1520s.
Henry and Cranwell knew him as one of the Kings think tank and they knew that he
was willing to do Henry's bidding over the divorce.
With that confidence and Archbishop of Canterbury who would do the kings,
will and Berlin at last gave in to Henry's imports unity's.
By December,
1532,
she was known to be pregnant and in January,
1533 they were secretly married.
The king was willing to go ahead and do that because he was convinced that his
first marriage would be declared to have been void,
but now with an pregnant,
things had to move fast.
In April,
1533 parliament was brought to pass the act in restraint of appeals.
UH,
crucial statute.
This declared that England was an imperial monarchy.
No foreign jurisdiction was valid within its boundaries.
No appeals against a judicial decision made in England could be taken outside
the kingdom.
And accordingly.
In May,
1533 Cranmer assembled the court,
a node.
Henry's marriage to Katherine of Aragon at in June,
1533 an already secretly married to the king,
was crowned as queen already six months pregnant with the future Queen Elizabeth
the first who was born on the 7th of September,
and in the same month,
September,
1533 the pope responded by excommunicating,
the king casting him out of the church,
but he held the excommunication in suspension in case Henry would begin to
behave,
but Henry didn't behave.
That wasn't his way.
In 1534 the parliament passed the succession act declaring the validity of the
annulment of Henry's marriage and his remarriage and fixing the succession to
the crown in the new line.
Oh,
that's what required from all major office holders to respect the act of
succession and act for submission of the clergy was passed to legally enshrine
the church,
the clergy submission,
and finally the act of supremacy,
which declared Henry the eighth to be the supreme head of the Church of England.
In some then the necessity of securing the Tudor Dynasty had led to England
entering into a state of schism,
schism.
They had rejected the jurisdictional authority of Rome.
They had asserted the royal supremacy over the church.
And in 1534 to five this was backed up with a flurry of executions of
individuals who dad to defend the Aragon marriage and the authority of the pope
and those who were executed included John Fisher,
the reforming bishop of Rochester,
who could not tolerate this.
And most famously,
Thomas Moore,
the former Lord Chancellor,
former good servant of the king who also could not stomach this and died for it.
So we now enter a third phase,
the Henry Schein reformation.
On the face of it,
the royal supremacy over the church had nothing,
whatever to do with religious reformation.
It was a rejection for reasons of state of the supposedly usurped legal
jurisdictional powers of the Bishop of Rome.
But it had nothing to do with Protestantism.
And it was not intended to inaugurate reform in matters of faith or worship.
But of course it did.
It took place in a context of the reformation in Europe.
It aligned England against Rome,
if not necessarily with the Protestant princes of Germany or the Protestant
cantons of Switzerland.
It gave an initial foothold to that minority who favored some measure of
religious reform and there were already people around the king who were prepared
to use that opportunity purposefully.
They'll necessarily with extreme caution.
Thomas Crum,
well certainly favored reform.
Queen Anne favored reform.
She received Protestant books which were secretly brought to her by London
merchants and read them with interest.
Thomas Cranmer favored reform as he had done for some years.
On the other hand,
most of the bishops and most of the new nobility were willing to go only so far
with Henry.
They would accept the royal supremacy for the good of the kingdom,
for the good of the succession,
but they hope that it will all end ultimately in a reconciliation with Rome.
So they would go along for the time being.
The key figure in all of this of course,
was Henry them himself and once he had the royals supremacy,
Henry found that he rather liked it.
He was happy to adopt a position of a moderate reformer of abuses and over time
he increasingly came to believe in his own propaganda.
He saw himself as a Solomon,
as a just Cya who had promulgated God's law and purge the land of abuses and
idolatry
and at the same time the king was notoriously susceptible to influence and if
those who held his trust,
we're able to steer things in the direction that they favored,
then the king might back them.
If they were cautious,
though they were always well advised to proceed with extreme caution in order to
retain the king's confidence.
He was willing to be influenced but he could react fiercely if he thought he was
being abused.
Well,
in the mid to late 1530s Thomas Cromwell and Thomas Cranmer certainly had the
king's trust.
They had served him very well as Archbishop of Canterbury and grandmas case or
in Cromwells case as vice Gerand in spirituals,
the office of administering the church on behalf of the king and they did a
great deal to mold developments in 1536 day issue,
10 articles of faith and a set of injunctions for the practice of worship and
the church which moved very cautiously in a reformist direction.
In 1536 Thomas Cromwell organized a visitation and inspection of the
monasteries,
which was deliberately intended to find the abuses and which led later in 1536
to the dissolution of all religious houses worth less than 200 pounds a year.
The smaller monasteries,
if it's not presented as an attack on monasticism in principle,
but as an attack upon abuses.
It was a severe shock and it was one of the issues which provoked in 1536
rebellion in the north of England.
That rebellion,
which we'll deal with on another occasion,
was suppressed in 1537 and in the aftermath of that suppression,
the larger monasteries were gradually cajoled and encouraged and bullied into
surrendering freely their possessions.
To the crown.
By 1540 every monastery or nunnery in the kingdom had gone.
In 1537 Cromwellian Cranmer engineered the issue of the bishops book,
a set of homilies,
which again moved cautiously towards Protestant definitions of faith.
In 1538 the great shrines,
the great centers of pilgrimage at Canterbury in Durham and elsewhere were
dissolved.
Their riches seized by the crown,
broken up on the grounds that they had been idolatrous,
Lee abused.
And in 1538 the Bible was issued in English,
the Great Bible translation into English,
which was actually based upon the translations of the Bible by William Tyndale
and Myles Coverdale,
both of whom were Protestants that was not officially admitted,
but it was a fact.
These were the only translations ready to hand,
and they needed to produce the Bible quickly.
The Great Bible then was issued,
and on the frontest piece,
the magnificent frontest piece of the Bible Shows Henry sitting in majesty
handing down the word of God to his grateful people.
It was not much doubt that by 1539 things had gone a lot farther than anyone
anticipated and that elements of reformed doctrine where being gradually
smuggled into Henry's church,
but in that year,
the king called a halt.
The situation had changed again.
Okay.
Another of the events of 1536 to go back a few years was the fall of Anne Boleyn
after her marriage to the king and the promising start,
the birth of Princess Elizabeth.
No male heir had been born and had suffered a series of miscarriages.
She was in a state of acute nervous anxiety,
understandably.
Eventually,
she was suspected.
Word was brought to the king planting suspicions that she had committed adultery
in her desperation to have a child.
Other accusations were brought against her.
The queen was arrested and executed.
Shortly thereafter,
Henry married Jane Seymour,
another lady of the court.
The death shortly after that of Queen Catherine meant that the marriage to Jane
Seymour was now of undoubted legitimacy.
Both of Henry's earlier queens were dead,
and in 50,
30,
1537,
she gave birth at last to a male heir Prince Edward Cath.
Jane herself,
uh,
died in child bed.
So the king had his son
that could have cleared the way for reconciliation with Rome and is more
conservative counselors hoped that it would do so quickly.
But here again,
Henry's personality proved vital.
By now.
Henry sincerely believed in his role as supreme head of the Church of England.
The question at issue was how he would exercise his power.
His conservative counselors persuaded him of the dangers of the growth of
radical Protestantism in the country.
They pointed out the Anabaptists had been discovered in London that there were
so called Sacramento,
Syrians at large.
These were people who followed.
The Swiss reformation is teaching on the nature of holy communion.
In 1539,
Henry was persuaded to endorse the act of six articles which returned England to
unambiguous Catholic doctrinal orthodoxy in matters of faith.
And in 1540 Thomas Cromwell having been accused by his enemies of secretly
encouraging heresy was arrested and swiftly executed is real crime was in fact
the fiasco of having arranged the king's fourth marriage,
his marriage to the German Princess Anne of Cleves,
which brought Henry into alignment with the Lutheran princes of Germany.
Uh,
Henry deceived by a flattering portrait was horrified when Anne of cleves
arrived who described her as a Flemish mare.
He refused to consummate the marriage and it was swiftly dissolved.
This was a lucky break for Anne of cleves who retired to a states in eastern
England where she happening,
lived out the rest of her life.
So she came out of this quite well.
All things considered,
Thomas Cromwell lost his head.
Now,
this phase of events is often portrayed as a return to full Catholic orthodoxy
accompanied by a reinvigoration of traditional worship in the parishes.
But I think again,
that goes too far.
What was ruling in the late years of Henry was not full Catholic orthodoxy.
It was really Henry's own peculiarly Edo syncratic conscience and desires in
matters of religion.
Henry would certainly burn the occasional radice radical Protestant if one was
caught,
but he also executed the occasional Catholic for opposing the royal supremacy.
On one occasion,
he made a demonstration by having several of each executed on the same day.
You can say what you like about Henry,
not a nice man,
a persecutor,
but he was an equal opportunity.
Persecutor Henry was listening to some of the conservative voices in the
council,
especially,
uh,
bishop gardener of Winchester and the conservative faction,
which circulated around Thomas Howard the Earl of Norfolk.
He came under their influence quite heavily and 1540 when Norfolk brought to his
attention,
his young niece,
Catherine Howard,
who became Henry's new bride,
his fifth wife,
pushed into his bed at the age of 18 by her uncle in the hope of assuring
greater influence for his faction.
Nevertheless,
although Henry was increasingly under the influence of conservative figures,
he never lost his trust in Thomas Cranmer and indeed he shielded Cranmer from
enemies who would have loved to bring about his fall.
And after the discovery of Catherine Howard's actual adultery and 1542 and her
execution,
the king was much less influenced by his more conservative advisors.
Yeah,
certainly the gradual drift of the 1530s in the direction of some kind of neo
Lutheran reform of doctrine had halted,
but England's religion under Henry and his later years was not full orthodoxy.
Parish religion was not as it had been.
The culture of the saints and the shrines and the relics had been greatly
reduced.
The cult of purgatory was gone.
The monasteries were gone.
I'd on the more positive side,
a new vernacular religious culture using the English Bible,
an English service books had come into being
and if really,
truly doctrinally Protestant people were still very much a minority.
They were a growing minority and to some extent a powerful minority.
They included some very powerful people whose potential influence was out of all
proportion to their numbers.
Cranmer was still the archbishop and he favored and helped reformers in the
universities and in the church.
In 1543 Henry's last Queen Queen Catherine Parr was who was as much his nurse as
his queen,
came into a position of authority and she again showed great sympathy towards
reform the so called Seymour Circle at court.
Those gathered around Edward and Thomas Cmo,
the brothers of Henry's dead,
Queen Jane Seymour,
and the uncles of young Prince Edward also favored Protestantism and above all,
perhaps in their direct influence,
the tutors who were appointed to the young Prince Edward and to his sister,
Princess Elizabeth appointed by Archbishop Cranmer.
We're all closet Protestants.
So all of this was the legacy of the Henry [inaudible] reformation.
It had not been a truly Protestant reformation,
but I think it marked a far more significant break with tradition than is
sometimes recognized.
Hmm.
Okay.
Let's move on now to a fourth phase.
The Edwardian reformation,
Henry the eighth of last guide in January,
1547 age only 56 though he'd been in a state of some decrepitude for years and
the new King King Edward was only nine and a half years old.
And that of course is another of those contingencies that helped to shape the
history of the reformation.
Edwards,
Uncle Edward Seymour led a group of reformed minded man and taking control at
the center of power.
Seymour was appointed protector of the young Prince and Duke of Somerset,
now as a Duke of Somerset and protect a CMO and his friends.
Prime interest was advancing their own power and influence,
but there's little doubt that he was also off sincere Protestant views.
And in that context,
archbishop Cranmer was able to exercise far more influenced and he had since
the changes in religion,
which were brought about in the next two and a half years,
suggest a very high degree of commitment of these men at the center.
They may not have known in 1547 just how far they were going to go,
but they certainly intended to go further than Henry the eighth hat and they
acted swiftly once they had the power.
In 1547 parliament was persuaded to repeal the heresy laws and the six articles,
no more burning of Protestants.
They issued reformist injunctions for the removal of images and the obliteration
of religious paintings by white washing them in the churches.
That's where in those paintings I described to you in Saint Agatha's,
ESB were whitewashed only to be discovered again 400 years later.
A book of homilies was issued.
Official sermons of broadly Lutheran sympathy in their doctrine,
religious guilt and confraternities were suppressed and their goods were
confiscated by the crown.
In 1548 communion was allowed in both kinds.
That is both bread and wine were administered to the Laity in the Protestant
style,
and in 1549 Cranmer issued a prayer book and an act of uniformity to insist upon
its use,
which was at least half Protestant in doctrine.
That prayer book brought a brief rebellion in the west of England,
the so called prayer book rebellion,
which centered in the counties of the southwest and led briefly to the siege of
Exeter before a royal army arrived to disperse the rebels and to follow their
dispersal with the savage repression of this resistance.
Something like 4,000 rebels were either killed or executed immediately after the
rebellion.
As a result though Somerset's dominance in the council was shaken and he was
replaced as a central figure by John Dudley,
the Duke of Northumberland.
That change at the center,
however,
did not lead to any change in religious policy.
In fact,
Dudley backed additional innovations in order to keep the support of Archbishop
Cranmer and indeed the favor of the young king himself.
Edward,
by this time,
had emerged as a youth of pronouncedly evangelical Protestant beliefs and
inclinations verging indeed on bigotry.
He was often described as the young Josiah Biblical figure,
the young king who would bring true reform and cleansing of the church.
Okay.
In particular,
in 1552,
uh,
further prayer book was issued a revised prayer book.
This one decisively and openly Protestant.
Yeah.
And it was backed in 1553 by an emphatically Protestant statement of faith.
The 42 articles.
Okay,
let's take stock.
The Church of England under Henry the eighth was a peculiarity,
personal blend of doctrinal orthodoxy with elements of reform in worship and
practice.
But a true Protestant minority had emerged,
especially in London and the southeast and among certain powerful members of the
social elite and under the boy King Edward the sixth and is to read regents.
True Protestant reform moved ahead rapidly over six years.
By 1553 the church of England was clearly Protestant in doctrine and in forms of
worship centered on the English Bible and on the prayer book,
and the nation had become deeply divided in matters of faith.
Yeah,
and that leads us to the fifth phase of this process,
the Marion reaction,
Edward the sixth the boy king died of pulmonary tuberculosis only a month after
the issue of the Protestant 42 articles of religion and the wheel turned again.
Okay.
Desperate to avoid loss of power.
The Duke of Northumberland proclaimed as Queen Lady Jane Gray,
the nearest Protestant successor who could be named except Princess Elizabeth,
who was left out because she was still stigmatized as illegitimate.
Henry the eighth his daughter,
Mary,
who at this time was living in seclusion in east Anglia,
was not willing to accept this.
As a daughter of King Henry and of Catherine of Aragon,
she raised support amongst the gentry of East Anglia,
formed an army and began to move towards London.
The Duke of Northumberland lost his nerve.
He disbanded,
his troops,
capitulated and gave himself up.
So after the turmoil of the previous 25 years,
Mary had become queen after all the thing Henry had sought,
so hard to avoid had happened.
Okay.
How far Mary's success in being able to raise troops and finding widespread
support for her succession to the crown,
uh,
how far it was a result of the fact of her tutor blood and that she clearly was
the direct heir or how far it depended upon the appeal of the fact that she was
known to be deeply loyal to the old religion.
That's an open question,
but a deeply loyal Catholic.
She certainly was.
Her young life had been blighted by the disillusion of her mother's marriage and
the kings subsequent actions she clung as part of our very identity.
You could say to the old religion and her subsequent policies bear the stamp of
that,
and they also reveal just how divided the nation had become by the stage.
Late in 1553 soon after her excession parliament was persuaded to Repeal Edwards
Act of uniformity,
which had enforced uniform Protestant worship in the nation.
Interestingly though,
80 members of parliament were brave enough to oppose that action.
Early in 1554,
Mary married,
she married Prince Philip of Spain,
the future King Philip.
The second and that marriage was accepted by parliament,
though with great reluctance and only after the suppression of a brief flurry of
rebellion in Kent where it's a Thomas Wyatt led a small army to try to seize
London and prevent the Spanish Spanish marriage.
The citizens of London shut the gates against him.
He was defeated and executed.
Then
in the fall of 1554 full papal jurisdiction was restored in England.
Cardinal Reginald Paul,
Great English churchmen who'd been living in exile in Italy arrived to absolve
the realm from its schism and was appointed Archbishop of Canterbury.
But interestingly,
he was only,
uh,
the,
the absolution of England from schism was only accepted after the pope had
agreed that monastery land would remain with those who had been granted it or
who had purchased it under Henry the eighth that would not be restored to the
church.
England.
Dan was part of the Catholic fold.
Again,
though on terms,
many Protestant ministers in the church were deprived of their livings and many
of them went into exile abroad.
Universities of Oxford and Cambridge were also purged.
Some 60 members of Cambridge colleges and some 80 members of Oxford colleges
went into exile abroad.
Something like 800 ministers or laymen and their families of pronouncedly
Protestant belief also went into exile from December,
1554,
those who remained in England faced the penalties of a revival of the Heresy
Act,
punishing heresy with death.
And the burnings began
between 50 and 55 and 15.
58,
over 300 people were burned at the stake.
Some of them were amongst the most notable figures of the Henry Schein and
Edwardian church bishops,
Latimer and Ridley to leading Protestants were burned at Oxford in 1555 Latimer.
They were burned facing each other,
uh,
in the marketplace at Oxford.
Uh,
Latimer famously calling out to Ridley as the flames came up,
be brave master Ridley play the man.
Archbishop Cranmer was also burned at Oxford in 1556 he had temporarily recanted
his Protestantism from his fear of death,
but then went back on his recantation,
declared openly his commitment to the new religion and is burned in 1556 holding
out into the flames.
The hand with which he had signed his recantation.
This hand hath offended.
He said
most of the people who are burned,
however,
we're not the great leaders of the church,
but humble people,
most of them from London and the southeast.
In fact,
almost half the burnings took place in London,
in the city of culture,
and in Canterbury.
The southeast was the focus of Protestant strength.
They were usually lay people.
Only a 10th of them were clergymen.
They were often young.
Most of them were under 30 and a very high proportion of those executed where
around 20 years old.
These were people who had never really known the old religion until had grown up
in the new and proved prepared to die for it.
Well,
the effects of this holocaust of Protestant resistance are debatable.
Certainly Mary,
her bishops and her advisors had simply never expected the resistance to be so
widespread or so prolonged.
But the fact that Mary persisted in her policy to the end really does her,
no honor.
If she had no reason to love her father's memory,
it's clear,
at least that she shared his implacability with those who opposed her.
And by doing so,
the persecution helped to cement England's religious divisions and associated
the old religion with a level of persecution that was wholly unprecedented.
They'd never been religious persecution of this intensity.
And indeed it was intense,
not only by English standards,
but by the standards of continental Europe at the time.
Well,
what might have happened given more time,
we'll never know
because Mary died in November,
1558 aged only 42
Christopher Hayes suggest us have a number of other recent historians that
Harrain appears to be an aberration.
Only in hindsight he thinks she might have succeeded had she began been given
time,
Protestant resistance would have lessened the old religion,
would have become reestablished fully a normalized,
and perhaps that may well be the case,
but there's also a sense in which one could say her reign was regarded by at
least some as a temporary interlude even before her death.
Mary was 37 when she came to the throne 38 when she married a Spanish prince who
was usually absent from her abroad,
seeing to the affairs office,
other possessions.
She was childless dis data.
A couple of Phantom pregnancies which gave her hope.
She had little prospect of bearing and air despite her desperate hopes both for
herself and for her faith for Mary.
All this was undoubtedly a personal tragedy and it's been suggested that she
died in a state of profound depression in her last months.
Both those who supported her and those who opposed her,
knew
that in the background was another claim to the throne Princess Elizabeth,
and that her accessioned to the throne would almost certainly bring about
another alteration in religion.
To some degree,
it could be anticipated well in advance.
What they didn't know though what at this time after the twists and turns of the
generation between 1527 and 1558 it would last and it would last partly because
of the nature of the religious settlement,
which Elizabeth introduced partly because of the way in which she was able to
defend it and partly for another very simple contingent reason.
When Elizabeth was proclaimed queen on the death of her sister on November the
17th 1558 she was only 25 years old and she lived to be 70
and more of that next week.